well good afternoon everyone I'm Joseph
Richert from our studio and I am
director of the our consortium and I'm
here with David Smith my fellow director
from Microsoft who is also director key
our consortium and what we'd like to do
is is give you some idea about the our
consortium and and why why we exist so
first off in simplest terms the our
consortium is a group of business
enterprises and philanthropic effort
enterprises who have an interest in
ensuring that the our language and the
our community thrive for the long term
so the consortium is the vehicle for the
participation of businesses in the our
community the way I think about it is
that to have a community like our
community there are three necessary
conditions you have to have people who
self-identify as part of the community
people who interact frequently and there
has to be a way for people to contribute
to the community so the our consortium
is a way for businesses to contribute to
the community and right now what we have
here is a list of the members and what
you see are the founding members our
studio and Microsoft and then on the end
there you see the addition this year of
the Moore Foundation the Gordon and
Betty Moore Foundation which I believe
is a significant development because it
shows that a well-established
philanthropic grant-giving organization
who's interested in the in promoting
science and technology in the United
States has you know recognized that are
is a key contributor and enabler for the
scientific community and on the bottom
here you see some organizations that
that are not directly making their
business around the our language like
Google for instance or you have here
this this little mountain there is
Ketchum trading which is a hedge fund in
Chicago these are smaller organizations
who recognize that they have a
significant dependence on the our
language and they want to become members
of the community so so here we have a
way for for businesses and other
organizations to become a member and we
see ourselves as the link here so the
possibilities are that we could be the
place that binds these you know the
community which is at the people level
industry which is a category above
collections of people the our foundation
which is of course an organization made
up of people who are also individuals so
this is this is how we solve the we see
ourselves as a link now there two major
ways that we provide will we provide
energy and money so the energy part is
exemplified by this this slide here we
have the concept of working groups and
if you're if you've ever worked in a
standards organization like the I Triple
E or you know other trade organizations
you can see that there's lots of
opinions about how things should be done
right and it's very important before you
do anything to try to achieve consensus
perhaps get some funding to work out
initial prototypes and that's what the
our consortium working group is for so
you see we have some some already
underway and this this graphic on the
right here is that's the the reference
architecture for the distributed
computing working group now what they're
working on is to try to figure out if
there is a
a single interface layer that say could
be built that would be the proper way
for people to write write to if they
were interested in using different
distributed computing back-end so it's
not an obvious solution and and they're
working at it we see ourselves as the
catalyst and we're delightful to see the
success that our ladies is having we we
funded our ladies and during the last
round last year just a small amount of
money and we certainly can't take any
kind of credit for the success but this
is a slide that they presented to us
when we we went through the exercise of
seeing how our investments were right
we're turning out and we're just
delighted to see how much progress
they've made and continue to make and
it's an example of sometimes you know
you have something that's working at one
level and then maybe a little bit of
money or attention in this case I think
maybe just attention and and it works
wonders a place where people can come
together so we mostly fund what we call
infrastructure projects but we have an
extended idea of infrastructure and and
getting people you know small
conferences and in ways for people to
meet are also part of our mission we
were interested really in complicated
projects so when we go out for a call
for papers what we like to see our
proposals from from groups or
individuals or groups of individuals who
were willing to take under undertake
something that will benefit a large
portion of the art community and
something big enough that it needs
organizational help so and then and then
we're the resource for the heavy lifting
so the our hub project which many of you
have probably seen a tutorial on
yesterday was some kind of
elevating project for the our consortium
what happens when you need to begin to
put together the infrastructure for a
modern-day build system that will last
through the 21st century this is this is
what it takes to be on the consortium
and it shows that it shows the
commitment that these companies have
made so to be a Platinum Member that's a
hundred K Jews per year a gold member
which is underneath that is 50 K and the
silver member is 25 k for organizations
that are over a hundred people what I'd
like to see is the growth in the
consortium with lots of smaller members
contributing because we're all stronger
when people become involved so there's
there's two major committees you can see
that is the Board of Directors that
we're on and that's involved with
strategic decisions and you know how
much money we have to spend the
infrastructure steering committee is the
the group that actually decides what
projects get funded and they issue the
call for papers and what-have-you and
this is a this is a list of the active
projects you know that are going now you
see I'm up there on the board because I
run the our user group support program
so if you're organizing a user group
there is some money to be had depending
on the size of the group so please look
at the our consortium web page and and
write to us and tell us about your group
and you see the prod the grants ranged
from small grants you know in the $5,000
range
to the our hub is a significant project
so we're prepared to undertake a you
know real infrastructure but our mission
is to spread the spread the money around
this is money that comes to us and dues
right now we're up to getting close
having handle that handed out a half
million dollars and we're pretty
efficient I think the last I look our
efficiency ratio is about 70 percent and
we'd like to even do better than that
so our that's the money comes in from
the companies they have an interest in
fostering the community the foundation
and the language and we're trying to
hand it back intelligent lis to people
who who have real contributions to make
so David huh
thank you joy I wanted to jump in at
this point if the tenant that way it'll
go forwards I want to jump at this point
and just give a little perspective from
the point of view of Microsoft and why
did Microsoft become a member of the our
consortium and it has to do with with
what I said if it's oh my my talk this
morning is that the the value of
software including our lies not just in
a technical capability but also in the
you co system that forms around it and
Microsoft has a lot of interest in our
having a thriving ecosystem around it
you know Microsoft is a fine and Noble
company but it doesn't do things out the
good out of the goodness of its heart
should it have one Microsoft is very
selfishly investing in the our
consortium to foster the growth and
success of the our community in its
technical capabilities to give you one
very specific example Microsoft has a
very vested interest in our being able
to access databases very well and there
is a DVI project that was funded by the
Arkansas so in order to unify the way
that are connecting with databases which
is very much in Microsoft's interests so
it's important from a talent perspective
both we at Microsoft and our customers
and partners that are working with our
need to be able to hire people and by
investing in the our consortium and
being public about that that helps us
with that our recruitment goals also
around the vendor network you know being
able to work with the other vendors in
the
like our studio like TIBCO like
everybody else and have just unified
discussions about how our is working in
the commercial environment is very very
important to us at Microsoft so from our
perspective we get very good value out
of that one thousand three one hundred
thousand dollars a year that we invest
in the our consortium which in turn gets
invested into the broader ecosystem as
Joe just described just to give some
summaries about the our consortium since
it's been running for a couple of years
now we currently do have thirteen
members four of which are that top level
our platinum never actually rather than
gold is listed there we would love to
have more so if you are working at an
organization which is doing a lot with
our please do talk to your leadership
about potentially becoming a member of
the our consortium and in turn
contributing to the ecosystem in the way
that I just described but the thing that
you know I think I'm most personally
proud of as a founding member I
remembered I'm sure the other members
are as well is the projects that the
members of the community have been able
to undertake through the our consortium
sponsorship and and and the budget the
projects with the working groups and the
social organizations that Jerry
mentioned as well another thing that I
think is really really important that
the our consortium has achieved is to
open up a conduit between the vendor
community that is working with Microsoft
and directly with the leadership of the
our foundation one of the the ways the
governance structure of the our
consortium is designed is that the our
foundation automatically has a seat on
the board participates in the board
meetings participates in the community
discussions and that has really improved
the communication back and forth between
the vendor community and the our core
group right now Robert gentlemen is
representing arc the arc foundation on
the board of the our consortium and you
know in general it's just providing a
secure long-term foundation for our as a
whole are as the eCos
from these vendors ested interests of
the vendors that are working around our
so what's coming up one of the projects
that the our consortium is investing in
right now and undertaking is a general
survey of the our community this is a
essentially an academic survey in
designs we spend a working group spent
about three months designing this survey
has only recently been launched but we
would love to hear from you and any
member of the art community broadly they
might be watching online or anybody who
is using our to provide information
about what you think about the past
present and future of the our project
there'll be a link at the end of the
presentation but please do visit the our
consortium blog or the our consortium
Twitter handle to see a link to that
survey there also a number of new
projects that have been already been
funded at kicking off soon you'd like to
read about those new projects that's on
the our consortium blog at the link
there and if you have been inspired by
projects that you or you and some
colleagues might wish to undertake there
will be a new round of proposals being
announced later on this year where you
can make an application and apply for
funding in the same way we saw so just
in general to wrap up the our consortium
is there to promote the growth and
development of our as a leading platform
for data science to provide support
directly to the our foundation through
that connection I mentioned a moment ago
to fund projects that are supporting the
our projects and the our community and
foster the growth of that our community
and then from the point of view of the
vendors to help enable the use of our in
commercial environments and foster
collaboration between those companies
that are using our in that commercial
sector so as I mentioned earlier on help
us to help you be part of that community
please talk to your company about
potentially becoming a member
think about projects and submit them to
the our consortium when the new round
comes out shortly have a look at the
existing projects that are currently
underway and if you'd like to check it
and help with those please do and follow
us and spread the word on Twitter and at
the blog
thank you very much
[Applause]